then again you're like looking at things
from like all different perspectives if
you're saying that there's that most
women I'll be you need to talk to most
women like children then obviously
that's still an argument to an exception
not the rule oh no I mean like most I'd
say it's more the rule like like I talk
to women every day and you know and like
I'm not saying there's not reasonable
women that you can have conversations
with I meet them all the time but I'd
say like there's a substantial
percentage of women that I I can't have
a conversation with them without them
bringing up some exception yeah but man
like if I bring that up like they're
pretty like they don't argue with me
when I say women like guys with money or
tall guys they're not like Daily's not
here saying like but but you know